nous sommes dans un petit village des
basses-alpes à quelques kilomètres à
peine des notes à broc ce vieux village
dont vous voyez en ce moment les toits
les rues bientôt les alentours a une
particularité sur 200 habitants au
dernier recensement 106 porte le même
nom donc la majorité s'appelle gracq
renseignements pris nous savons
maintenant que ce nom est d'origine
grecque
il vient de gracchus 106 personnes
portent donc le nom de gracq quelquefois
le même prénom quelquefois aussi le même
sur nos
madame comment vous appelez-vous bien
que jaune monsieur comment vous
appelez-vous le juge doyon droite régis
gracq domi clair que maurice jeudi face
aux 106 personnes portant le même nom se
doit poser certainement un sérieux
problème dans la distribution du
courrier comment vous en sortez-vous
est-ce que j'étais arrivé de distribuer
du courrier à des personnes à qui ça
n'était pas destiné à ça m'est arrivé ça
s'arrange toujours claude la rage autour
parce que c'est le pass enfin et
vieillards porte donc presque tous le
nom de crack dans ce vieux village situé
sur un haut plateau à quelques 800
mètres d'altitude
[Musique]
monsieur le maire comment vous
appelez-vous je m'appelle cosy maurice
gracq avoué c'est parce qu'une
plaisanterie finalement dans le vidal
exactement oui nous avons environ une
cinquantaine de familles de gracq ici et
nous avons 1 106 électeurs qui s'appelle
jack
[Musique]